we know you're working with of a new  directive on Thor 2 or Thor the dark  world you got Sir Alan Taylor who's  Gareth Jones director what was it like  working with him what did he bring to  the it's a sequel and are you a fan of  Game of Thrones I am fan of Game of  Thrones I have to say I'm not I'm not  very good at keeping up to speed  so we said I haven't seen all of the  reason you know the recent series I know  there's been a big who are about certain  plot developments but you know Alan is  amazing he has this extraordinary  breadth of vision really about about the  world of the dark world just the scale  of it what he imagined Asgard to be what  the depth of and and the specificity of  his imagination about  extending  the the reach of the film and taking the  audience into into parts of the Thor  universe that they haven't seen yet and  I found that really exciting  you